just start again or we should did you
bring the bill yeah let's just stop okay
so maybe just to quickly just recap what
we did just before the break so so we're
looking at this binary tree on top of
the sequence of operations in the way we
constructed the tree was we looked at
what happens when the data structure
processes this sequence of operations we
took every operation and we looked at
what memory what probes into memory
doesn't doesn't make right so maybe make
this maybe this update here makes K
probes each of them X's as a cell and
for each of them you look at the cell
and then you you go back in time and
find the most recent place where this
cell was also exist okay so for this
cell maybe the most recent time was over
here doing that query and then you take
this probe and then you assign it to the
lowest common ancestor of these two so
that's how we construct the tree and
then we argued that if we can prove that
for every node in the tree the number of
probes assigned to it is somehow
proportional to the subtree size then we
get a lower bound on the total number of
probes this make sense it has to be
performed throughout the sequence so
what remains to prove this is this claim
here that all the nodes there has to be
a lot of probes assigned to it and one
way to prove it is again via one of
these encoding arguments that we had
before like Edison Park and let's try to
do it again
during this time is that so we're
looking at some note B you can get a
note B it's sitting somewhere in the
tree it has a left subtree and the right
subtree and then there's something that
happened before the left subtree and
there's something that happens after the
right subtree and then in the middle you
have inside here you have intermixed
updates and queries that's the tree so
what will be encoding this time the
Ellis wants to encode and sent to Bob
it's going to be see these these updates
over here so similar to before maybe
let's call this the random variable
gives all of this let's call it ill and
maybe the left and this is right maybe
we can call this B for before and maybe
we can call this a for Apple so so in
this communication game alice is going
to whole know be L and AH she knows
everything up to this point if we're
just going to ignore everything after
those only E and Bob knows this but
doesn't know L again all these the bits
that are signed here independent of and
be so so entropy is very bearable even
if I condition them bnr is so how many
updates add on this subtree well in the
very root in the left subtree does in
over 2 to the D in over 2 updates if you
go down to something like in order 2 to
the D plus 1 updates in the left subtree
each of them has L bits so this is the
now encoding game we're trying to send a
message that's shorter than this to get
a contradiction to make sense how they
going to do that and we so we assume
that okay say you conviction that the
size here is in terms of epsilon D is
just going to be the different media so
we're going to assume this that this is
a small set make sense now we're going
to use this assumption again - to have
this a one-way message from Alice to Bob
that allows Bob to to learn all these
bits that were all these things that
were written here
so and this is actually it's going to be
much simple in the previous technique
and also quite a lot simpler than if you
look at the Trask own domains paper
there they have things actually two-way
communication game and they have use
Bloomfield the data structures two
compressors something that represents
sits and and also if you go look at the
payment would be quite a lot more
complicated than this proof but they
also had updates and queries at random
positions which makes everything more
complicated six positions in this proof
here so what is Ellis going to do she's
going to run the data structure all the
way through to this point here she's
just going to run the data structure and
from the data searching when she looks
at all the probes that are being made
and she obtains this set via vehicle
just you know figure out what is the set
of probes being assigned to the node B
okay and her message is just master Sims
the sales pro pipe so this is a set of
probes and they probe cells with
addresses so she just sends all the
cells that are being probed all the
cells corresponding to the probes in
here mixes so if this is one of the
probes it touched the cell with address
a so she sends the silver Atmos a and
how in what does it what time or what
version of the silver she sent she sends
the cell it's its address and the
contents it had right at this point
one since
yes right after followed by ill just
before this right sub-tree make sense if
she just runs it looks at one of the
probes that are signed to be she finds
all the cells that are being accessed by
these probes and then she just look at
one with the contents of these cells at
this time and that is what she sends to
Bob
she's principal feels we could be a
function of the deltas and so on yeah
yeah definitely
yeah and then it's Bob Stern that's the
whole message and what is Bob do Bob
just runs all operations in and okay so
then there okay let's do a little bit
more for me okay so see he runs Dee up
to this GG he runs all of this right
because he also knows B so he can run it
up to this point then he skips ill and
then he updates memory
according to Alice's messages
it doesn't make sense so he runs it up
to here now you have some sort of
representation of the data start in
memory which is the same as Ellis head
at this point then he skips all of this
and then the set P of V tells you some
changes right so then he just goes and
updates these contents and now what we
do is IV has done that it just runs the
operations in R then we hope that you
can answer all his process all these
operations correctly they'll not even be
any that I'm wrong this time let's try
to argue that this will actually give
the correct processing of all these
operations so the way we argue it is
that we say okay you want to prove that
during Bob's processing of are whenever
he reads the cell it has the same
contents as if you run the whole
sequence and then it would be correct
does that make sense so you just want to
argue that has the same contents so the
way we do it is okay look at a probe in
R and into some cell of address a and
look at it and assume it this is the
first time that a is being accessed
doing aa to do it the first time a cell
with address a is being accessed during
I want to argue that the first time it's
being accessed it has the correct
content because if it's correct the
first time it's going to be correct the
next times the next time so so so maybe
this operation here X's is a and this is
the first time it's being accessed in
this subtree then there are several
cases so that was there's a probe that
makes this exit so it's called the probe
Pete so this probe is assigned to a node
node three that several cases so so what
could be the case so it could either be
assigned to an ancestor of E maybe it's
assigned all the way up here okay what
does that mean
well if it's assigned to an ancestor it
means that the last time it was accessed
before this time was in some subtree
over here
it has to be somewhere in be said missus
you cannot be in a because you always
find your obviously that the last time
was like just prior to you yet so that
will be in the past so this has if it's
an ancestor V it has to be in B which
means it's not even changed during L and
then of course it's the correct content
because Bob at the correct contents of
this time okay so what's the other case
if it's assigned to B then Alice's
message told us the cried cut correct
contents so then this again correct any
sense everything in in this set and
finally what if it's assigned to a
descendant of me then it means that the
last time was XS was actually in this
subtree which contradicts it's the first
time it's being accessed so so this
means that power plants all of these
correctly now it gets me to argue that
that fully recovers all the infield
wrote over here okay and and that's why
we chose this bit reversal permutation
that's just to argue that these queries
is the right sub-tree tell us everything
we need to know about the left subtree
okay so let me just convince you why
that's the case
so okay
so if you look at this subtree here and
you look at because everything is powers
of two in these sub trees you have some
number I reverse and you have I plus one
reversed so on if you look at these bit
patterns here they're going to look
something like this they're going to
then there's some prefix and then that's
going to be one the same prefix they're
all going to be consecutive numbers and
when we do the reversal of all of these
it's going to have the prefix reversed
on all of them and then it's going to be
make sense
is it the indices in the array that
you're updating and you have all because
it's about two you have all of these bit
patterns here so you have every single
combination here so what these updates
are adjust evenly spaced updates they're
spaced by 2 to the D with some offset
that's determined by this prefix so make
sense so that just so actually all the
operations in this subtree here just if
you have the array they're just spaced
evenly it's some ether please there's
some offset the term bad prefix and the
same in the right subtree
they're also spaced by the same distance
just with another offset so what you
have is that in the left subtree you
have an update here an update here an
update here an update there and if you
look at the queries in the right subtree
they're also going to be spaced like
this right so since we're just about
also mating updates and queries that's
what this pre this big reversal does for
us it's just that if they alternate all
the time so now that bob can answer all
of these prefix some queries bob again
he knows B so and he knows I so you can
subtract off the contribution from the
updates in here and
updates in there and he just gets the
some of the blue ones and so like like
before he learns the person when he
learns the next one you list the third
one you know it's the fourth one so he
learns all of them and that's
so and that's the full proof of this
technique right because now what we
obtain so how long is the message that's
being sent by Ellis right the expected
size of this set so the expected length
of the message under our assumption was
epsilon in or to the D and written there
was a cell with an address in the
content so that's maybe W bits for the
contents W bits for the address so this
is some or in or two to the D W and what
was the entropy n over 2 to the D Omega
n over 2 to the D times L so W and L
within constant factor of each other and
Epsom is too small we have the
contradiction so epsilon has to be large
has to be a constant
so in every single node in the tree the
right subtree essentially has to read
everything in the left subtree that's
basically what it's saying and that
gives the log in lower bound that's
before and again this the speaks is
login right because baby what we're
saying is that everything the right
subtree has to read everything in the
left subtree you cannot hope to to argue
anything more than that you'll never
have to read more than everything from
from the left subtree so so log in is
the highest lower bound we can prove our
using this approach I mean what rule is
epsilon playing here I mean why didn't
we just get epsilon equal to 1 well
maybe if Sun is 1/2 words there's 2w
maybe L and W have affected far away
from each other whatever right so but it
is a constant there's some constant it's
not that it needs to be larger than some
constant yeah and you can work out the
constant if you like and it's probably
pretty tight no Yuri assume that the
data store no no no this is just no no
here I also assume the date so it
doesn't make errors if you have
randomized testers you can again modify
the pupal between yes so so there's
another way of modifying the proof in
the original paper instead of
considering a binary tree you consider a
tree that has a different fan-out so
it's like a Bieri a tree which is chosen
proportional I think to the max of I
think you said B to be something like
the max of T U and C Q over log N or
something like that and then you have
more operations of the cheap type than
off the other one I mean you can make
the admins work
and you get a tight trailer for all you
get tight low amount for all trade offs
between the parameters in the original
paper they also consider what happens if
Hill the number of bits in an update is
smaller than the word size and they also
have tied trade off for that so it's
completely tighten in all the parameters
yeah this is from surah mm no not this
proof but that proof is this group is
not purpose no I think it's in the same
idea with this whole information
transfer tree but I think it's a little
bit simpler here and in this it's a V
would make these sort of very digits and
reverse them or is it still the same
thing yeah I guess I think you could do
B area and then reverse it I I didn't
try it that's not what they do in the
written one they have random there are
positions and then they argue that there
are many interleavings in this pattern
here and then you still learn a lot but
maybe not everything that's there really
improve just random locations that you
and the complication there is that then
Ellis I think they have to I don't think
they assume that Ellis knows Bob's
queries I might be mistaken I don't
think they assume that me give some
communications but you can still give a
protocol
so let me move ahead to the the next and
the last week sort of well the last one
I'm going to present to you at least and
proving lower bounds for these problems
for the Namek data structures so this
Login was in the highest until favor of
mine from 2012 that proves to the
flowing lower bounds we're going to get
lower balance of this form so the query
time assuming a log in log update time
word size squared this basis the lower
bound from the chrono gram method we saw
in the beginning a square almost so
let's try to so for this proof we need a
different problem because this problem
has a log in all bounds so we're not
going to prove the lobe on there but
it's very closely related the problem
we're going to look at the problem here
is just a 2d version of this problem so
the data structure problem we're looking
at is known as s range counting so you
have points in 2d
they have weights in this case you can
insert points as an operation you can
insert a point and then a query
specified by a point as well and then
you have to sum everything inside this
this range into everything that's to the
bottom left of the query point
this is sort of a fairly common type of
query in SQL database if you think about
like this is something that matches
select all that it has where maybe where
a is less than equal to something and B
is less than equal to something that
gives you like a two-year age it's a
very natural promos and competative
geometry so you want to this is a
promise just so you get these insertions
of points and then you need to answer
these queries that ask for the sum
inside a range and what we assume here
is that the points are have integer
coordinates on an N by n grid okay so
the in focus I invite him that's the
input domain
and so this proof technique here builds
on top of the chrono gram method but add
some more to it and it combines this
kilogram thus a technique called self
sampling by penny groggy Salwa and vida
from 12 2010 okay so that's this is a
technique for proving static lower
bounds aesthetic data structures so this
is this one here sort of a combination
of the two so what is the idea the ideas
again you're going to go back to this
cronograph method where we have time
here and then we have these epochs of
geometrically decreasing size right so
the first one size beta beta square and
so on beta to the I and the last one of
sort of distance the iPhone a size beta
to the I so this is beta to the I point
insertion and the last one has say in so
there's log base beta n of these epochs
and what what does the insertions look
like in the hot distribution
surprisingly you can actually have these
you can have these points sets the very
much inspired by this one so so in the
last little in the lattice epoch
it's just J comma reversal of J for J
equals 0 to n minus 1
so that's the point set and that gives
an the idea if you look at this point
that you draw is sort of very well
spread the points are sort of all over
in the weights that are being assigned
to the points yeah weights in this
version yeah so each each point has a
weight like before maybe 15 6m and just
the eye that Prague is just you do J
equals 0 to beta to the eye and you just
scale this bit reversal so you have
something like J times in or beta to the
the eye and then you have I J reversed
it's just little well spread point sets
that are being scaled up okay it's not
we're not going to use it in this proof
because it'll be too technical
but the idea is just they're spread all
over and it looks like the the 1d case
so we have these points it's first you
have a lot of points being inserted then
you get smaller points are being entered
in the smaller one and so on on top of
each other and what we're going to try
to prove this time is that so the
previous techniques always argued about
reading at least one self from some time
period right that something was written
during a time period this time we're
going to prove something more than one
self we're going to - so we have it so
we can we define these sets of memory
cells at the very end the krona gram
right so we have all these the cells
that'll last being updated during epoch
but we speed up in a called seal of
which Beethoven if you don't remember
right CI is the set of cells in memory
at the very end which were last updated
during epic I and after this all of this
we have a uniform random query ok that's
the hard one this is the sequence of
queries is it shrinking with time yes
it's shrinking of time yeah the updates
are shrinking with time
they sort of what is the scaling but and
prepare to the end it's the coordinates
of the points so this is just the point
set just to if you want to know what the
points it looks like I said so you here
you just to see the later updates that
are happening and they sort of spreading
the points out more or are they
concentrating they're much less no they
are putting them in exactly the same
grid that's sort of the intuition that
that's why okay when I reverse this I
only do it with fewer bits in the number
okay so I spaced out much more than the
space times much more but we'll take off
the same space yeah yeah so it's
something like the blue ones here and
then maybe have a few red ones that have
spread much more and so on
so at the same points it just fewer
points but scale up to fit the input
region based on over bound is so this is
X this is tight for as long as the
update times the least log into the 2
plus epsilon and
this on was tightened and you know that
you can have if you have update time
lock square and then the query time is
lock square or something in the upper
bounds but it's almost tight it is
actually tied so if you don't have
weights on the points if you just need
to count them then this then there's a
matching of about there's pretty close
to tight
we're worried so we have all these sets
again and this time we want to prove
that you need to read not only one sail
from each set but but many many cells
from each set so a lot of claim is that
if beta again is it's large enough beta
that's enough
it must be the case that these biggest
look at the probes made by the query Q
at the very end look at how much does
read from a guy all the epics the
expected number of things has to be log
based beta then so that's what we hope
to prove that you don't need to read
just one cell from each other you need
to read almost log n cells from each
other and there are log base beta up in
epics
so the lower bound if you sum them up
overall I again use linearity of
expectation but the fan lower bound will
be log base B of n square and then as
you can guess you probably just said
beta to be somepony to you w for
everything to work
in particular let's say beta greater
than CTW to the tip then this holds some
big enough pulled over and now we want
to try to prove it
and we're going against uses encoding
that idea precisely the same as before
so Ellis again the same set of us before
us well so what is Ellis had with input
so Ellis has so if you use UI to denote
the updates of epic I else has all the
updates bob has everything I accept to
live so it's called the whole thing you
accept you I and Bob needs to learn UI
that's the idea like the same setup as
before precisely the same setup okay
let's try to to give a protocol here
and
protocol is going to some parts would be
similar to the chrono Graham might as
well reuse the nice ideas they have so
we already know you know up from before
either always send all the stuff in the
little air pockets right because that
was very small if the goes down
dramatically there's not very much
information on many bits in the stuff
that's being updated out here all of
this was small first this was the number
of bits here going to be proportional to
beta to the I minus one updates here
each of them can change to you cells
each of those cells has W bits so so
that's roughly in the number of bits it
takes to set this betas mean is pretty
big that number is much smaller than
beta to the I times L if we have a bit
weights don't make sense maybe just read
over here the D edition of everything
Hills this is the bomb we're trying to
beat it had beta to the I insertions
each with Elbit keys right so the points
that was fixed but the values on them
were ill bit numbers so we're trying to
beat that and this is going to be
smaller for our choice of beta if Illin
so far so good and so if we try to think
about what did we do before so before in
the reading program Bob just took every
query and try to run it and then many of
them didn't be anything in CI so you
would answer it correctly but this time
you know if you're just assuming the
second contradiction that it's lessening
to epsilon log based Beethoven still
going to read if all the queries could
read something in there right so you
can't answer any of them correctly so
far so far all right so it's going to
have to send something more to help Bob
but ideally you would like to send the
set CI because then Parker has
everything but CI is too big because see
I had beta to the I times the update
time cells so it's too big you want to
send all the all the cells in this set
with their contents that's going to be
too big so so you do instead is that you
use you cell sample so Ellis is going to
down sample this set is CI so Ellis
samples cells and CI independently
probability beta it's a random subset of
this cell of this cells okay so okay so
how lock it so let's call this sample si
so the expected size of this set is of
course 1 over beta times the size of CI
and this is going to be the size of C is
is most beta to the I to you again
because the update times most to you and
then each of them has W bits so to the
total so what Edison says he just sends
si to Bob then this message is again
going to have the same length as that
one up there one cuz you down sample
just make sense so Ellis picks the
sample with them which go up a little
bit down
so let's look at the memory find CI and
picks a random sample of it and sends it
to Bob and now yeah constants yeah so
that's the W vector here the contents as
well yeah and now what we want to argue
is that Bob can still answer and quite a
few queries and not all of them but you
can still enter a lot of queries so so
how we're going to argue that so let's
try to look at a query up under our our
assumption right most of the queries of
thought are going to read G less than
equal to say I don't for epsilon this
makes sense if the expected number of
probes is epsilon log beta then there's
going to be many queries that read
little most of the time so what happens
if you if you look at one of these
queries that reads at most this many
cells what is the chance that if Bob
just runs the query alone afterwards
updating everything in the sample and
everything the future what's the chance
he can answer it correctly and you can
answer correctly if all the cell's he
reads from epoch I I in the sample so
the chance you can answer it is it's
going to be so this each cell was
sampled in depending with probability
one over beta right so this is the
chance you can answer a query make sense
and let's just put in what election is
for if so not these beautiful okay if
you rearrange this it's going to be in
to the - voice so there's actually a
pretty good chance that he can answer a
query
okay sir so how many queries are then
total the input that's N squared queries
right and each of them you can answer
with probably something like into the
minus four epsilon so you so we expect
you can answer something like into the
two minus five swim quiz it makes sense
to everyone we expect that you can
answer a lot of queries from the same Bo
but not not all of them now the hope is
that the query seek an answer reveals a
lot of information and if you think
about it a little for a little while
you'll actually realize that they're
definitely sets of this many queries
that do not reveal a lot of information
so here's the point set look at this is
n to the 1 minus Phi Epsilon so let's so
maybe you have maybe the queries you can
answer are all sitting in here in the
beginning this is the input range and
maybe the queries you can answer all the
ones in here and no one else in fact
you're going to only let you know this n
minus n to the 1 minus points and points
that are not even included in any query
range so you don't learn anything so you
have to take care and I there's no time
to prove it here but you can actually
argue that there is a set of this many
cells where the queries you answer
actually I will spread in this input
range okay so that takes a lot of work
to prove but you can argue that the idea
is still is there's many queries that
survive and you can even enforce that
the queries that survive a sort of well
spread in the open region and what we
really need is so what we can actually
prove this is this we can prove that it
from this sample this is let's call this
Q the set of queries that survive the
sampling if you think about these
queries so all of them why is that the
output right the output the sum of
everything in this range
so each of these sums is like a linear
combination of the weights on the points
right it's just the sum of the point so
it's linear combination of the weights
and so we can talk about the rank of all
these linear combinations make sense
controller CIA right so how do you
through something like that we give some
weight usually yeah you loser
so what we actually do what what I did
in this paper is you don't just sample
and consider what's the chance of one
query survive you create something that
we call mega queries so you look at a
whole set of say beta to the I over
pulley log queries that are already
spaced out then the query time goes up
proportionally but then you can argue
that that many of these well spread
point sets that all survive the same
thing and if you take the union of all
these well spread point sets then you
get will spread queries so it's pretty
long argument it's like a 10 page I mean
that you have all these well spread
queries that's the idea you can enforce
by by looking at many together that are
already spread apart you can you can
argue that there will still be will
spread queries that survive this is just
that all I am going to change the little
bit I am not done yet nope yeah I'm
saving in a twist to the end okay so so
what we have here is that so we can
think of all these queries that survive
reveal a linear combination of the
weights right so when we can actually
prove is that the rank just write it
like this the rank of all these linear
combinations it's going to be more than
beta to the I over say tu w to the
something like that so make sense to
everyone you guess are they have a
reasonably large rank all these queries
that survived the the sample whether
that means that the amount of
information that all these answers
reveal about epic I is going to be
proportional to beta to the I over GU W
to the fifth times L so make sense
we will that many linear the independent
constraints or the sums so they're going
to reveal a little quite a lot of
information all these queries easily now
it seems that we're already done right
because how long was the message the
message was faded to the I minus 1 - eww
long and we said beta to be something
like something very large so this is
going to be beta to the I over to you w
to the 9th is the length of the message
for our charged parameters so this is
much less than the amount of bits we
learned make sense so seeing that we
already reached the contradiction right
because the message is much shorter than
the amount of bits we learn but there is
this problem with the protocol so far so
anyone that has not that say didn't know
in advance that can tell me what's the
problem with the current protocol it's
quite subtle
thirty-six Paulette what is - yeah it's
pretty sudden it's getting late
okay so we argued that there is this set
cube that ball can answer correctly from
this message innocent
the problem is Bob doesn't know what Q
is
actually you cannot even detect it so so
what happens if you look at what L is
sent to send the sample and just send
everything in the little the future
epochs what Park try to do is you just
start running all the queries all the N
squared queries when it has a query you
starts simulating the query algorithm
when it reads something he goes and
looks at le so he can run the data start
you up to just before a guy again so he
knows what looks like at this point he
can make all the changes that happen
here based on Alice's message and then
he has a sample of Seanna
so what Bob does it so he starts to run
the query algorithm and it makes a probe
into memory okay so you can look at that
as his message so what's it changed
during the small epochs if it was he
knows he has the correct contents right
so then he can continue if it's in the
sample then she also knows she has he
knows he has the right contents because
the last problem is if it's not in this
it's not an SI there's no way for Bob to
know whether or not it's in CI or it's
not in one of the past epochs you know
you cannot see whether the cell should
be is in CI - si or whether it's in one
of the big ones
he doesn't know which is the case right
so there lot of queries Bob can answer
correctly but he just doesn't know which
ones this wasn't the problem before
we're in the universe that in the
chronograph that was not the problem
there actually I guess it was actually a
problem there but there was only a small
constant fraction that read anything
outside that there was only a small
conservation that failed here it's
almost everyone that fails it's only a
small very small fraction that actually
succeeds it is that's the main reason
that's difference here before actually
they could not detect it some of them
were in the epsilon fraction would being
answered incorrectly but here it's
almost everyone who's being answered
incorrectly it's only a tiny fraction
that is correct majority will not work
here okay if you're getting more than
one over two to the L fraction correct
isn't that good enough 1 over 2 to the L
fraction yeah but L so how big is no no
that's not enough like let's say if you
think else you're thinking random
guesses right maybe 102 the object might
be enough yes yeah 1 or 2 to the L might
be enough and that's the last tip of the
that's missus there's something missing
here so that this will be something like
what you're saying I want to go to the L
fraction it's just a way of two humans
but you're right if it's more than 1
over 2 to the L fractions and it has
some things so so the last step here is
to add a little more to Alice's message
so what L is can do is she can actually
compute cube right because she has all
the information she can compute so she
knows the queries that Bob wants to
answer this is a lot of queries so it's
not good enough if Ellis just tried to
tell Bob what is the set Q because it's
way too big but what she can do is so we
know the rangas is its large so amongst
the queries you can find this many
queries where the linear combinations
they compute a linearly independent
so she finds exactly this many queries
and then what we add to the message is
just the indices of such set up queries
su she finds Q star sub secured instead
the size of Q star the dissertation
little bit rank of Q star which is then
at least beta to the eye and she since Q
star to Bob so the one point is she does
not send the answer to the queries she
sends the indices of the queries is a
query can be specified by to log in bits
so this is going to cost something like
e to the I to log in over Q W and if we
go back how much information did we
learn from this message because now what
Bob does is just he updates everything
according to Ellis's message and then he
only runs the queries in Q star and
though she can answer correctly and
those reveal a lot of information about
Epica it seemed that they reveal this
much information this is the Stephanie
that waits to be large exactly so beta
to the so we you learn this many bits
read t UW and you spend this many bits
so to get a contradiction but take a
meal L to be at least bigger than to log
in so the whole proof easily also that
if L just puts me log in here what man
will say soon
with selling them we even need them is
to send them in here so what I mean I
think we force another problem yeah I
guess you could actually use what you
said in Italy for to to DL fraction is
correct put it I'm actually not sure it
is enough for this problem because if it
has like if the outputs of the data so
if you look almost like an error
correcting code then it will probably be
enough I'm not quite sure if it's enough
yeah I have to think more about it in
this problem we move this step which is
become like yeah yeah yes but these are
also very much reveals the what I want
to say in the last 10 minutes okay so
this is like okay so no still need a
large wait yeah because you still need
put it on the login tip yeah still mean
log in bit Waits
except okay so this lower bound here
only works so if you think about what's
going on here it only works if the
output of the query has more bits than
it takes to describe a query
so input and and that's really inherent
to this technique right so the the
problem must have the property that the
output of a query reveals more bits than
it takes to describe a query that's not
the bottleneck here and so in particular
this technique completely fails if
you're looking at decision problems
right where the output is one bit to a
query there there's no hope of using
this technique to prove anything so that
was sort of the main open problem after
this paper can you somehow modify this
to prove log squared lower bound for
decision problems the reason why fails
is again this there's no way if if Ellis
doesn't say which queries pops you
should try to answer there's no way and
it can no longer simply the queries in a
message because they're too big and you
will not get a contradiction and a many
net from data structure problems that
are decision problems and so what I'll
show you now is just some recent work
maybe already if you attended stock how
you would have heard watching talk about
it so this is a recent work from this
year so progress is slow in this area
another six years before anything
happened so so what we prove here is
hungry who's also sitting here and
watching from from this year's stock is
if we prove a lower bound off something
like this so it's going to be log in to
the one point five over log to you
w cute is faster remember step correct
and that's quite sure about the
explosion I think it's this is the right
bound and so basically so it's not all
the way to lock squaring but this is for
a decision problem and in particular
very related decision problem it's the
decision problem where weights here are
just bits and instead of computing the
sum you compute the sum mod two similar
problem
it was also conjectured by Mohammed
Roscoe
nice obituary this proving a log squared
lower bound that something beyond login
was mentioned as an open problem in in
particular he mentioned this as a nice
candidate for for proving such a little
arm so I think explaining the new
technique would take maybe two hours
more we tried a lot of times to give the
talk in one hour and that's almost
impossible but I think now you
understand the barrier for decision
problems I did the Pearson he just
completely breaks down because there's
no way for Bob to know which queries it
can answer after the same thing we're
gonna give you the main new idea in this
this proof so we're going to do is that
we go to skip this step here with
sending queries to simulate right
because that's not going to work
everything else is the same in the
beginning right you said in the sample
you send the future cells and so on
problem is okay so Bob on the other hand
wants to answer the queries so what what
Bob does so somehow we know already that
there's a reasonable chance that if we
look at a random query that ba can
actually answer it right it's going to
be you know we say wait 1 over beta and
if it reads T cells or epsilon log base
paid up in cells it's going to be able
to enter it with probability a into the
minus Epsilon this isn't reasonable if
you look at a random query there's a
reasonable chance
Bob can answer it
so what we do in the paper is that we
instead of the encoding game we look at
a one-way communication
game instead so it's almost the same
setup it's just
instead of Bob having to recover a UI
Bob just has to answer this random query
but our proof boils down to is to show
that from an efficient data structure
one can actually a correctly answer this
random query a probability slightly
better than random guessing this is
going to be something like probably 1/2
plus into the minus Epsilon something
like this can answer it with a slight
advantage of a random guessing and it
turns out that this is so far the
message from LSU just not enough the
main idea is to say okay so so Bob when
he gets this query starts to run the
query with me assuming that he can
answer it correctly that probes some set
of cells maybe they're the right ones
maybe then not once in a while we know
that the right ones like every one away
into the Epsilon's time some probability
they're going to be the right set of
cells and they're fairly many of these
cells that you keep probes and what we
do is then we argue that so Bob read
some set of cells when he tries to
answer the query and rare occasions it's
the correct set of cells we prove start
applying information through reading
inequality to assess that you have this
answer that depends on a set of cells
and it's going to give a little bit more
for me so it should we define random
variable for each cell he reads one set
T
and then we have the Angeles called
that's another random variable it's a
binary random variable and then we say
we have this event that happens fairly
often that the contents of these cells
completely revealed B you can turn that
into an agreement saying that okay in
such a case that also exists a small
subset of the cells a much smaller
subset of the cells that still has some
information about the random variable B
and then we apply another round of
random sampling and then hopefully we
sample the cells that are needed to
learn something more about the answer to
the query this is fairly detailed but it
really boils down to trying to prove
that since this is fairly often the
correct set of cells there must be some
information in there that can help us
answer the query and go read it if you
like it
wait so long for now and I think you're
probably tired with all the ideas but
but the barrier that we tried to work on
was this one because we cannot say which
queries to simulate so I think there's a
lot of open problems left here in
particular it's still not a log squared
and lower bound for these decision
problems it's only log to the 1.5 and
the best-known our bound is a log square
and I would if I were to guess I would
guess that the right bound is log
squared was this particular problem for
this particular problem yes but still
proving you know log squared for any
decision problem would be interesting
yeah so what else do it so so locks but
it's probably the current barrier I
think proving for decision problems is
this thing that's closest to being
doable I would say of course breaking
log squared would be fantastic that no
proof now cube the proof n to the
epsilon lower bounds is like a big open
problem we expect we expect that it
grows by 1/5 every dimension but we
don't know but that's what we expect you
have to pay one lakh per dimension
there's supposed to be some reason why I
love squared is the best no one's been
able to prove right
I think it's so far okay so there's one
so what are we doing it one way of
thinking about what we're doing this
funny epic eye sometimes we're treating
this as a static data structure problem
and we prototyped what we need to read
login all over the log log and croaks
from the static problem and login
alarming is also the barrier for static
problems so far and then the other one
is these geometric decay that gives
another log in or log again this time
thing that pretty much why this is what
we can squeeze out right now you need
something completely different so in
principle I mean you don't see a major
barrier log squared and it's this we're
stuck we're stuck yeah I think for
dynamic problems there's definitely more
I think if you look at static problems I
think the log barriers seems very hard
to break I would I would say here I
don't see any concrete reason why we
should not be able to probe into the
epsilon lower bounds but we just don't
know how to do it Mihai petrescu again
has a very nice paper that's called
Swartz per normal lower bound for
dynamic problems from I don't quite
remember which year it was shortly
before he passed away and that one
introduces like a three phase
communication game it's called the multi
phase problem maybe some of you have
heard about it and that one seems very
obvious that the lower bound should be
polynomial but we still don't know how
to prove it and I think many people have
tried unsuccessfully but it doesn't seem
to be an inherent reason for dynamic
problems why you can do it very very
strong technique you will apply it
strongly study no no okay so for some
problems there are
I like this problem here
because there are upper bounds that if I
have a static solution I can turn it
into a dynamic one by paying a log
factor this property in particular so so
if I have a strong dynamic low bound I
get a stay low by this is one lock
yes that's what problems that are
decomposable in this way where you can
combine the answer to a bunch of data
structures to get the answer to the full
set so for such problems
there's a barrier for prune dynamic
robots but that's but me highs problem
does not have this property then you can
combine arguments when all these
arguments you add a weight only once
right the update phase yeah dynamic
problems you could you could add weights
and I mean you could add and decrement
over time yeah not me this is complete
had instance it doesn't seem to be
necessary here is the problem it allows
it
yeah the protein allows yes but the
Hadean see just doesn't need it this
thing is exploited however you try to do
the same with sometimes and I don't
think so I think not off the top of my
head but I mean yeah this is this to say
you know yeah I guess if you times also
box let me just stop there Thanks
I don't want questions before
[Music]